[Musica]
volevo innanzitutto ringraziarvi per la
splendida accoglienza sono veramente
emozionata di parlare a un così bel
pubblico e spero che non impigliati
pomodori credo che sia un momento molto
rozza che per me parlare del deserto
cos'è il deserto il deserto la penultima
frontiera dalle famose parole di star
trek non è l'ultima ma la penultima
perché la penultima perché a deserto
dice giochi contiene un suono il suono
del vuoto il suono di un ampio spazio ci
sono molti definizioni di deserto come
poeta uno può pensare il grande silenzio
come scienziato come scienziato il
deserto una palestra è una palestra che
ci permette di poter capire molte cose
sul nostro pianeta è una palestra dove
c'e un un incontro tra il cielo e la
terra tra l'acqua e la terra tra il
fuoco il ghiaccio ci sono tanti tipi di
deserti e qui c'è una carrellata di
deserti del sistema solare non
necessariamente messi nell'ordine perché
mancava l'etichetta per cui vi lascia un
pochino indovinare dove ci troviamo
se ci troviamo sulla terra o altrove e è
possibile vedere l'incontro di diversi
materiali
il vento che scolpisce crea delle dune
dune che possono essere nel nulla nella
profondità dello spazio nei deserti del
nostro pianeta materiali diversi ceneri
vulcaniche sabbia di quarzo sabbia di
basalto sabbie nere sabbiose sadico
minerali e pietre preziose che noi non
sappiamo neanche che siano preziose però
sono molto piccole che danno questi
colori incredibili queste forme scolpite
dall'area scolpite dall'acqua scolpite
dalla dalla natura che decora la
superficie e la pelle della terra come
un meraviglioso disegno e noi possiamo
anche vedere
ok possiamo vedere letti di argilla
sedimenti che sono stati erosi si sono
accumulati ci dicono che là c'era
l'acqua l'acqua un grande tema nel
deserto perché è un è un fattore
limitante noi sappiamo che l'acqua è
presente in grandi quantità né alla
almento fondi tale i deserti e un grande
paradosso tutti i deserti del nostro
pianeta hanno delle grandissime riserve
d'acqua ma quello che ci affascina di
più è il fatto che l'acqua deposita dei
sedimenti e questi sedimenti ci dicono
c'è stata acqua qualche miliardo di anni
fa qualche milione di anni fa
magari soltanto una settimana fa ho
poche ore fa è il tema dell'acqua un
tema molto importante perché io mi
occupo di capire se su altri pianeti ci
possa essere vita e si parte da un
presupposto che un pianeta deve avere un
ecologia e l'ecologia bisogno di acqua
così come conosciamo noi l'anno la vita
e l'applicazione fondamentale prima che
principale è quella che noi facciamo
ricerca su marte non su marte per gli
messo altri pianeti in futuro su malta
sappiamo che c'è stata acqua marte
profondamente diverso dal nostro pianeta
oggi perché è un gigantesco deserto
freddo in passato marte aveva un
atmosfera forse aveva comunque fiume
aveva la si vede dalle bellissime
immagini che che possiamo vedere che
ritornano delle varie missioni e marte è
molto più piccolo della terra e ha perso
la propria atmosfera forse durante il
primo miliardo di anni
il primo miliardo della vita questa vita
questa questa la vita di questi pianeti
tutti i pianeti del nostro sola
incominciata aldo nello stesso momento e
poi ogni pianeta si è volta in una
maniera diversa
una cosa molto importante che nei
deserti noi impariamo i limiti estremi
della vita come la conosciamo noi per la
limitazione dell'acqua ma si possono
fare tantissime altre cose si possono
testare delle tecnologie per esempio se
io manderò verso marte devo prima sapere
come questo ora sarà capace di scalare
una buna o come questo rover sarà capace
di muoversi attraverso le rocce
quindi noi utilizziamo i deserti come un
ambiente in cui poter testare alla fine
prima di mandare un roberz un certo
pianeta una strumentazione sul certo
pianeta come si muoverà e che per forma
e performance sarà un altra cosa
interessante
l'analogia ne parliamo di analoghi
analoghi planeta e ma analoghi su cosa
ci sono tantissimi livelli di analogie
di differenza forse sono più le
differenze che sono importanti ma le
analogie possono essere del tipo
geologico la morfologia possiamo avere
dei galli possiamo avere delle strutture
geologiche sono state rose e dall acqua
tanta acqua poca acqua quando è successo
questo
e come potete vedere dalle immagini ci
sono diversi tipi alti piani bassi piani
letti di argilla
io sfido chiunque a capire da queste
immagini alle mie spalle dove sia stato
preso il lago il lago de seccato su
marte o su uno dei nostri pianeti
secondo voi qual è quella a o b
pensateci un pochino insomma posso
anticiparvi che una di queste foto è
stata presa in un ambiente della valle
della morte che io ho studiato da
parecchi anni a circa 2009 sono andata
sono rimasta completamente affascinata
da tutta una serie di aspetti l'aspetto
scientifico che parlava la mia mente
l'aspetto diciamo tipico del luogo
dell'energia enorme del luogo che parla
il mio cuore è anche dall aspetto di
poter sopravvivere in questo ambiente
quindi sopravvivere alla mia missione di
ricercatrice che parla alla mia pancia
tutti gli elementi vengono coinvolti la
sopravvivenza alla curiosità e l'empatia
della condivisione anche di quello che
io imparo con tutti voi
e una cosa che anche molto affascinante
nell'ambito degli specifici sono tanti
tipi di deserti questi deserti vengono
definiti nell'ambito di quanta acqua
abbiamo è un è una costante lotta nella
retata quanta acqua il deserto riceve e
si va da 2 mm all'anno come nel caso del
deserto di atacama a 200 millimetri
l'anno fino ai primi semidesertici di 5
6 volte di più noi qua siamo in ambiente
mediterraneo quindi abbiamo fino a 7.700
1000 mm per comparazione con i 700 1000
a 2 mm e che non piove quasi mai dire
che quando piove
la pioggia non è sufficiente per avere
vegetazione e anche animali e anche
microbi il deserto di atacama è molto
affascinante per questo perché non c'è
sostanza organica non c'è dna i microbi
sono morti o moribondi perché non vivono
lì ma sono trasportati dal dal vento e
dopo un po arrivano lì cadono e muoiono
il deserto di atacama è molto importante
perché è il deserto dei deserti il
deserto più arido del nostro pianeta e
perché così ai dopo tutta una serie di
fattori innanzitutto non piove non
arriva neanche la nebbia la nebbia del
pacifico di cucchiai l'aria che arriva
dall oceano pacifico in sudamerica non
riesce a penetrare nel deserto la l'aria
carica di umidità nel sud america che
arriva dal polmone del bacino
dell'amazzonia non riesce a penetrare
quindi si chiama una doppio cono d'ombra
donno don dan e se come una bomba
schermata dalla pioggia e piove
veramente molto poco però possiamo dire
che questa pioggia che noi possiamo
avere anzi illuminista stessa riesce a
sostenere alcuni microbi
noi non abbiamo microbi nel suolo
comunque ne abbiamo molto pochi in
superficie andando in profondità se ne
tornò di più e se ne trovano sempre di
più man mano che ci sono molti studi che
continuano negli ultimi dieci anni però
cosa abbiamo abbiamo questi queste
distese di sali che si sono formati
milioni di anni fa quando avevamo tanta
acqua che adesso sono scolpiti
dall'erosione dal vento a formare queste
bellissime strutture che però sembrano
morte voi li avvicina rito cos'è questo
blocco di marmo un blocco di saks al e
poi vi avvicinate guardate si guarda si
martello si dà una grattatina e che cosa
succede dentro questo ammasso di sale si
trova quella cosina verde quello
quell'ombra una una piccola ombra di
vedere cos'è questa roba io proprio non
ce ne mangio tutto assaggio tutto sono
molto curiosa quindi non se non solo il
verde lattuga ma sarà veramente un
pochino di natura che cos'è quel verde
sono dei microrganismi che si chiamano
ciano batteri che vivono un pochino
dappertutto tanti ambienti vivono nelle
acque vivono nell'oceano e se noi
andiamo a vedere vediamo queste cellule
rosse cosa sono queste cellule rosse
sono delle cellule rosse che sono stati
colorate sono state colorate perché sono
ancora vive queste cellule riescono a
utilizzare l'acqua al minima quantità di
acqua che viene assorbita dalle sale
tutti voi avete magari il sale nella
vostra cucina che a un certo punto se
non lasciateli diventa duro perché
diventa due perché assorbe l'acqua della
dell'atmosfera della vostra cucina e e
poi si sindhu rifica la stessa cosa
succede lì questa cosa questo è successo
anche su marte su marte ci sono depositi
di sale e anche malte oggi potrebbe
avere quel minimo di atmosfera di
umidità che in presenza di sale può
creare un microambiente in cui alcuni
microrganismi potrebbero vivere
ci sono molti esempi di questo ad
esempio nella death valley nella valle
da molte abbiamo altri depositi di sale
con un condominio di microrganismi che
vivono in questi depositi non si non si
vedono dall'alto non si vedono dal
satellite non si vede neanche se io mi
avvicino devo proprio andare guarda e
scavare
ci sono anche altri tipi di deserti ci
sono deserti in antartide con me questo
qui questo è un esempio del deserto
della b con valley è un deserto freddo
in cui si abbiamo precipitazioni nevose
però per la maggior parte dell'anno
l'avidità è data dal fatto che fate un
po freddo non sempre nevica ancora
questo deserto è fatto di di rocce che
si chiamano stern stone che contengono
degli organismi che solo un pour simili
a quelli di atacama non è più sale e
sono dei grani di quarzo ma ancora sono
sono riescono a vivere in questo
ambiente ancora altri esempi che
possiamo avere
alle volte gli organismi non vivono
dentro le rocce vivono al di sopra delle
rocce sepe sfruttando l'umidità dellai
oppure vivono al di sotto questo è un
esempio del deserto del namib che nel
centro sud africa che è un altro deserto
bellissimo che è supportato non dalla
pioggia ma è supportato dalla da questa
da questa nebbia quest umidità che aveva
dall'oceano
poi abbiamo delle forze le pozze nei
deserti le pozze sono molto importanti
perché queste pozze riescono a dare un
piccolo sollievo agli organismi che
vivono in queste forze si formano in
seguito a fenomeni molto violenti come
temporali improvvisi in cui piove in
un'ora o in pochi minuti quello che in
teoria dovrebbe piovere sei mesi cioè la
distribuzione anche dell'acqua che è
molto importante e ha il duplice effetto
di creare delle pozzanghere che durano
poco possono durare pochi giorni possono
durare poche ore possono durare pochi po
poche settimane l'esempio che io studio
dura un paio di settimane la bellezza di
questo cos'è l'evaporazione enorme
soprattutto d'estate ma ci sono questi
microbi che in questo caso sono
b che hanno bisogno dell'acqua di
maggior quantità dell'acqua non gli
basta più soltanto la una pellicola
piccola da quando hanno bisogno di tanta
acqua anche se poi pochissimo tempo e
sia una fioritura algale nel giro di
poche ore nel giro di poche ore questi
microrganismi vivono si riproducono e
lasciano le spore ci sono anche altri
esempi sempre il deserto di atacama ma
anche il deserto della deval e le
fioriture ogni quindici anni ci sono
degli anni più piovosi quindi piove
molto di più e i semi delle piante dei
fiori che sono stati dormienti dieci
anni nel nostro pianeta
dieci anni sono un periodo lungo ma non
così lungo potrebbero essere anche
centinaia di migliaia di anni perché
l'expo e degli organismi micro casi
possono vivere anche tanto tanto e poi
abbiamo queste bellissime fioriture che
sono effimere lui hanno veramente molto
poco
io parte della merce cala conduco nel
deserto del mont avic nella california
centro meridionale e la deval e la valle
della morte e uno è una scusa un sul
territorio del deserto del mali che
ancora più caldo perché è una fossa
tettonica e al di sotto del livello del
mai perché per cui c'è un ulteriore
effetto di evaporazione
l'aia che arriva dal pacifico deve
passare diverse se harrah's diverse
montagna ogni volta che passa una catena
montuosa di l'aria diventa sempre più
secca un ambiente che è stato veramente
affascinante che ho cominciato a
scoprire quello del cratere delle lupi
libiche rimane nella parte nord della
del vale il criterio b b sono un posto
veramente mistico è un posto sacro ai
team di sciascio ni per cui è molto
anche difficile fi della ricerca che sia
rispettosa ma è molto interessante
perché abbiamo depositi di argilla che
sono molto simili a quelli che sono
attualmente investigati
su marte e abbiamo anche dei sedimenti
di tipo la giusta che ci dicono che c'è
stata molta più acqua nel passato e una
ricerca che interdisciplinare perché
coinvolge il contesto ambientale cioè
capire l'ambiente come l'ambiente evolve
quali sono gli estremi della temperatura
abbiamo temperature massime 48 gradi a
meno 16 gradi questa è l'ambiente in cui
io lavoro molto lavoro da sola perché
devo andare lì devo raccogliere un
campione per vedere i microbi nel
momento in cui fa più caldo 48 gradi 15
agosto oppure devo trovarmi d'inverno
quando fa più freddo perché mi occorre
quel campione
ovviamente devo andare quando c'è acqua
quindi io devo andare
quando piove quando ci sono le tempeste
tutti scappò dalla the valley il range
ormai mi vedono arrivare quando piove
arrivavo salva perché è importante se li
né prima né dopo
perché anzi bisogna soli prima perché
prima bisogna capire cosa succedeva
prima avevo un campione di quando il
terreno è più secco arriva e dopo perché
bisogna capire cosa è successo dopo
misurare la profondità dell'acqua quanto
2 ma non durante
non durante perché come potrete vedere
un cielo tempestoso la mia povera
macchina in questo palco deserto dopo un
evento di flash flood non c'è più la
strada quindi uno non vuole trovarsi in
quel momento
e c'è questa dimensione dell'avventura
della rimanere fedele a un programma da
eseguire e mantenersi vini riuscire a
sopravvivere alla calura o alfredo alla
solitudine anche alla paura di rimanere
sodio volte tutti noi abbiamo una
grandissima immaginazione stare al buio
di notte fermarsi nel deserto da soli o
mamma mia che ci sarà detto cespuglio la
nostra fantasia incomincia a lavorare
lavorare immaginando ci mostri più
spaventosi mostri che abbiamo ri dentro
la nostra pancia la nostra paura la
nostra sicurezza
però quando si è lì soli nel silenzio
nel silenzio si si si si incominciano a
sentire delle voci le voci dell'intuito
le voci del capire cosa si fa
all'indomani per avere un campione
migliore un campione ambientale da da
studiare e c'è la dimensione del
silenzio e del cielo stellato la de
ballet a uno dei cieli stellati più
importanti del mondo è una zona molto
importante perché non c'è molta molta
luce per cui si imparano soltanto a
sentire il suono del silenzio ma si
impara a vedere il colore del buio e ed
è una sensazione veramente incredibile e
la sensazione ancora pink olive quando
si incontra qualcuno e si ha voglia di
veramente comunicare quello che si è
imparato e su questa dimensione vi
volevo lasciare con soltanto uno spunto
perché anche noi col mio team di ricerca
giriamo il mondo e alle volte visitiamo
molti paesi ci troviamo a parlare a
molta gente a molti ragazzini e molti
bambini di di tantissime comunità e e
vederli sorridere quando noi parliamo di
scienze planetarie della ricerca di vita
veramente una cosa che ci fa continuare
questo tipo di lavoro non soltanto per
noi come scienziati ma anche per quello
che possiamo passare alle prossime
generazioni
grazie tu
[Musica]